IAL election results from the diaspora
are in they favor the incumbent Felix
chti but it's too early to gauge a trend
to determine who's willing these are
uncertain times in the
DRC observers from the cararta center
have released a statement saying several
people were killed in the leadup to the
poll the voting process was assist l in
21 polling stations with serious
irregularities observed in several of
them this data represents a limited
picture of election day
proceedings opposition leaders say the
election is a sham and they'll reject
the results people in kinasa are worried
about the
outcome the government is to blame we
need proper roads to avoid the
logistical problems we saw on voting
the last election was more organized I
know we can't have a perfect election
but this was not good many congales are
anxiously waiting for the results they
have mixed feelings about what has been
going on in the election and some say
they feel that the country is headed for
a disputed PA cathine soy Al jazer
kesta make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer